The following content is provided under a Creative Commons license. Your support
a Creative Commons license. Your support will help MIT OpenCourseware continue to
will help MIT OpenCourseware continue to offer high-quality educational resources
offer high-quality educational resources for free.
for free. To make a donation or view additional
To make a donation or view additional materials from hundreds of MIT courses,
materials from hundreds of MIT courses, visit MIT OpenCourseware at ocw.mit.edu.
We start a brand new exciting topic, dynamic programming.
dynamic programming. Yeah. So exciting. Actually, I'm really
Yeah. So exciting. Actually, I'm really excited because dynamic programming is
excited because dynamic programming is my favorite thing in the world in
my favorite thing in the world in algorithms. And uh
algorithms. And uh it's going to be the next four lectures.
it's going to be the next four lectures. It's so exciting. Uh it has lots of
It's so exciting. Uh it has lots of different facets. It's a very general,
different facets. It's a very general, powerful design technique. We don't talk
powerful design technique. We don't talk a lot about algorithm design in this
a lot about algorithm design in this class, but dynamic programming is one
class, but dynamic programming is one that's so important and also takes a
that's so important and also takes a little while to settle in. We We like to
little while to settle in. We We like to inject it into you now in 006.
inject it into you now in 006. So in general,
So in general, our motivation is designing new
our motivation is designing new algorithms.
And dynamic programming, also called DP,
also called DP, is
is a great way
a great way a very general,
a very general, powerful way to do this.
Um it's especially good and intended for optimization problems, things like
optimization problems, things like shortest paths. You want to find the
shortest paths. You want to find the best way to do something. Shortest
best way to do something. Shortest paths, you want to find the shortest
paths, you want to find the shortest path, the minimum length path.
path, the minimum length path. You want to minimize, maximize
You want to minimize, maximize something, that's an optimization
something, that's an optimization problem. And typically, good algorithms
problem. And typically, good algorithms to solve them involve dynamic
to solve them involve dynamic programming. It's a bit of a broad
programming. It's a bit of a broad statement. Uh you can also think of
statement. Uh you can also think of dynamic programming as a kind of
dynamic programming as a kind of exhaustive search.
exhaustive search. Uh which is usually a bad thing to do
Uh which is usually a bad thing to do because it leads to exponential time.
because it leads to exponential time. But if you do it in a clever way,
But if you do it in a clever way, by dynamic programming, you typically
by dynamic programming, you typically get polynomial polynomial time.
get polynomial polynomial time. So one perspective is that dynamic
So one perspective is that dynamic programming is approximately
programming is approximately uh
uh careful
careful brute force.
brute force. It's kind of a funny combination.
It's kind of a funny combination. A bit of an oxymoron.
But let's take the idea of brute force, which is try all possibilities,
which is try all possibilities, and you do it carefully, and you get it
and you do it carefully, and you get it to polynomial time. There are a lot of
to polynomial time. There are a lot of problems where essentially the only
problems where essentially the only known polynomial time algorithm is via
known polynomial time algorithm is via dynamic programming. It doesn't always
dynamic programming. It doesn't always work. There are some problems where we
work. There are some problems where we don't think there are polynomial time
don't think there are polynomial time algorithms, but
algorithms, but when it's possible, DP is a nice sort of
when it's possible, DP is a nice sort of general approach to it.
general approach to it. Um
Um and we're going to be talking a lot
and we're going to be talking a lot about dynamic programming. It has a lot
about dynamic programming. It has a lot of different There's a lot of different
of different There's a lot of different ways to think about it.
ways to think about it. We'll look at a few
We'll look at a few today.
today. We're going to warm up today with some
We're going to warm up today with some fairly easy problems that we already
fairly easy problems that we already know how to solve, namely computing
know how to solve, namely computing Fibonacci numbers, which is pretty easy,
Fibonacci numbers, which is pretty easy, and computing shortest paths. And then
and computing shortest paths. And then in the next three lectures, we're going
in the next three lectures, we're going to get to more interesting examples
to get to more interesting examples where
where uh it's pretty surprising that you can
uh it's pretty surprising that you can even solve the problem in polynomial
even solve the problem in polynomial time.
time. Probably the first burning question on
Probably the first burning question on your mind, though, is why is it called
your mind, though, is why is it called dynamic programming? What does that even
dynamic programming? What does that even mean?
mean? And I used to have this spiel about uh
And I used to have this spiel about uh well, you know, programming refers to
well, you know, programming refers to the I think it's the British notion of
the I think it's the British notion of the word, where it's about optimization.
the word, where it's about optimization. Optimization in American English is
Optimization in American English is something like programming in British
something like programming in British English, where uh you know, you want to
English, where uh you know, you want to set up the program, the schedule for
set up the program, the schedule for your trains or something. I think is
your trains or something. I think is where programming comes from originally.
where programming comes from originally. But I looked up the actual history of
But I looked up the actual history of why is it called dynamic programming. Um
why is it called dynamic programming. Um Dynamic programming is invented by a guy
Dynamic programming is invented by a guy named uh
named uh Richard Bellman. You may have heard of
Richard Bellman. You may have heard of Bellman in the Bellman-Ford algorithm.
Bellman in the Bellman-Ford algorithm. So this is actually the precursor to
So this is actually the precursor to Bellman-Ford. And we're going to see
Bellman-Ford. And we're going to see Bellman-Ford come up naturally in this
Bellman-Ford come up naturally in this setting.
setting. Um
Um So here's Here's a quote about him.
So here's Here's a quote about him. Says, "Bellman explained that he
Says, "Bellman explained that he invented the name dynamic programming to
invented the name dynamic programming to hide the fact that he was doing
hide the fact that he was doing mathematical research."
mathematical research." At
At He was working at this place called
He was working at this place called RAND, and uh under a Secretary of
RAND, and uh under a Secretary of Defense who had a pathological fear and
Defense who had a pathological fear and hatred for the term research.
hatred for the term research. Uh so he settled on the term dynamic
Uh so he settled on the term dynamic programming because it would yield it
programming because it would yield it would be difficult to give a pejorative
would be difficult to give a pejorative meaning to it, and because it was
meaning to it, and because it was something not even a congressman could
something not even a congressman could object to. Basically, it sounded cool.
object to. Basically, it sounded cool. And
And So uh that's that's the origin of the
So uh that's that's the origin of the name dynamic programming. So why is it
name dynamic programming. So why is it called that? Who knows? Uh
called that? Who knows? Uh I mean, now you know, but it's not it's
I mean, now you know, but it's not it's a weird term. Just take it for what it
a weird term. Just take it for what it is.
It may make sense, some kind of sense, but
but All right. So we are going to start
with this example of how to compute Fibonacci numbers. And maybe before we
Fibonacci numbers. And maybe before we actually start, I'm going to give you a
actually start, I'm going to give you a a sneak peek
a sneak peek of what you can think of dynamic
of what you can think of dynamic programming as. Uh
programming as. Uh and
this this equation, so to speak, is going to
equation, so to speak, is going to change throughout today's lecture. In
change throughout today's lecture. In the end, we'll settle on a sort of more
the end, we'll settle on a sort of more accurate perspective.
accurate perspective. The basic idea of dynamic programming is
The basic idea of dynamic programming is to take a problem,
to take a problem, split it into subproblems, solve those
split it into subproblems, solve those subproblems, and reuse the solutions to
subproblems, and reuse the solutions to your subproblems. It's It's like a
your subproblems. It's It's like a lesson in recycling.
lesson in recycling. Okay. So we'll see that uh
Okay. So we'll see that uh in Fibonacci numbers. So you remember
in Fibonacci numbers. So you remember Fibonacci numbers, right?
Fibonacci numbers, right? Number of rabbits you have on day n if
Number of rabbits you have on day n if they
they reproduce.
We've We've mentioned them before. We were talking about AVL trees, I think.
were talking about AVL trees, I think. Uh so this is a the usual
Uh so this is a the usual uh you can think of it as a recursive
uh you can think of it as a recursive definition or recurrence on Fibonacci
definition or recurrence on Fibonacci numbers.
numbers. It's the definition of what the nth
It's the definition of what the nth Fibonacci number is. So let's suppose
Fibonacci number is. So let's suppose our goal,
our goal, uh an algorithmic problem is compute the
uh an algorithmic problem is compute the nth Fibonacci number.
And I'm going to assume here that that fits in a word, and so basic
that fits in a word, and so basic arithmetic, addition, whatever is
arithmetic, addition, whatever is constant time operation.
constant time operation. So
So how do we do it? You all know how to do
how do we do it? You all know how to do it anyways, but I'm going to give you
it anyways, but I'm going to give you the dynamic programming perspective on
the dynamic programming perspective on things. So this will seem
things. So this will seem kind of obvious, but it is a it's We're
kind of obvious, but it is a it's We're going to apply exactly the same
going to apply exactly the same principles that we will apply over and
principles that we will apply over and over in dynamic programming, but here
over in dynamic programming, but here it's in a very familiar
it's in a very familiar setting.
setting. So we're going to start with the naive
So we're going to start with the naive recursive algorithm.
And that is if you want to compute the fib nth
if you want to compute the fib nth Fibonacci number,
Fibonacci number, you check whether you're in the base
you check whether you're in the base case.
I'm going to write it this way.
So F is just our return value. You'll see why I write it this way in a moment.
see why I write it this way in a moment. Then you return F. Uh in the base case,
Then you return F. Uh in the base case, it's one. Otherwise, you recursively
it's one. Otherwise, you recursively call Fibonacci of n minus one. You
call Fibonacci of n minus one. You recursively call Fibonacci of n minus
recursively call Fibonacci of n minus two. Add them together. Return that.
two. Add them together. Return that. This is a correct algorithm.
This is a correct algorithm. Is it a good algorithm?
Is it a good algorithm? No.
No. It's very bad. Exponential time.
How do we know it's exponential time, other than from experience? Uh well, we
other than from experience? Uh well, we can write the running time as
can write the running time as recurrence.
recurrence. T of n represents the time to compute
T of n represents the time to compute the nth Fibonacci number. How can I
the nth Fibonacci number. How can I write the recurrence?
Good throwback to the early lectures, divide and conquer.
I hear whispers. Yeah?
Yeah. T of n minus one
T of n minus one plus T of n minus two
plus T of n minus two plus
plus constant.
coefficient. I don't know how many you have by now.
So To compute the nth Fibonacci number, we
To compute the nth Fibonacci number, we have to compute the n minus first
have to compute the n minus first Fibonacci number and the n minus second
Fibonacci number and the n minus second Fibonacci number. That's these two
Fibonacci number. That's these two recursions. Uh and then we take constant
recursions. Uh and then we take constant time. Otherwise, we do constant number
time. Otherwise, we do constant number of additions, comparisons, you know,
of additions, comparisons, you know, return. All these operations take
return. All these operations take constant time.
constant time. So that's the recurrence.
So that's the recurrence. How do we solve this recurrence? Well,
How do we solve this recurrence? Well, one way is to see this is
one way is to see this is Fibonacci recurrence. So it's the same
Fibonacci recurrence. So it's the same thing. There's this plus whatever, but
thing. There's this plus whatever, but in particular, this is at least the nth
in particular, this is at least the nth Fibonacci number. And if you know
Fibonacci number. And if you know Fibonacci stuff, that's about uh
Fibonacci stuff, that's about uh the golden ratio to the nth power,
the golden ratio to the nth power, which is bad.
which is bad. Uh
Uh We had a similar recurrence in AVL
We had a similar recurrence in AVL trees. And so another way to solve it,
trees. And so another way to solve it, it's just good review,
it's just good review, say, oh well, uh that's at least
say, oh well, uh that's at least two times
two times T of N minus two. It's going to be
T of N minus two. It's going to be monotone. The bigger N is the more work
monotone. The bigger N is the more work you have to do
you have to do because to do the N thing you have to do
because to do the N thing you have to do the N minus first thing.
the N minus first thing. So we could just reduce N minus T of N
So we could just reduce N minus T of N minus one to T of N minus two. That will
minus one to T of N minus two. That will give us a lower bound.
give us a lower bound. And now these two terms now this is sort
And now these two terms now this is sort of an easy thing. You see that you're
of an easy thing. You see that you're multiplying by two each time.
multiplying by two each time. You're subtracting two from N each time.
You're subtracting two from N each time. How many times can I subtract two from
How many times can I subtract two from N?
N? N over two times before I get down to a
N over two times before I get down to a constant. And so this is equal to two to
constant. And so this is equal to two to the
the N over two.
N over two. I mean times some constant which is what
I mean times some constant which is what you get in the base case.
you get in the base case. So I guess I should say
So I guess I should say theta.
theta. This thing is theta that.
This thing is theta that. Okay, so it's at least that big and the
Okay, so it's at least that big and the right constant is fee. In
right constant is fee. In the base of the exponent.
the base of the exponent. Okay, so that's a bad algorithm. We all
Okay, so that's a bad algorithm. We all know it's a bad algorithm.
But I'm going to give you a general approach for making bad algorithms like
approach for making bad algorithms like this good. And that general approach is
this good. And that general approach is called memoization.
And this is a technique of dynamic programming. I'm
programming. I'm going to call this the memoized dynamic
going to call this the memoized dynamic programming algorithm.
I settle on using memo in the notes. Yeah.
The idea is simple. Whenever we compute a Fibonacci number,
Whenever we compute a Fibonacci number, we put it in a dictionary.
we put it in a dictionary. If and then when we need to compute the
If and then when we need to compute the N Fibonacci number, we check is it
N Fibonacci number, we check is it already in the dictionary? Did we
already in the dictionary? Did we already solve this problem? If so,
already solve this problem? If so, return that answer.
return that answer. Otherwise, compute it.
Otherwise, compute it. Okay, you'll see the transformation is
Okay, you'll see the transformation is very simple.
Okay, these two lines are identical
these two lines are identical to these two lines.
to these two lines. Okay, so you can see how the
Okay, so you can see how the transformation works in general. You can
transformation works in general. You can do this with any recursive algorithm.
do this with any recursive algorithm. The memoization transformation on that
The memoization transformation on that algorithm
algorithm is we initially make an empty dictionary
is we initially make an empty dictionary called memo.
called memo. And
And before we actually do the computation,
before we actually do the computation, we say well, check whether this
we say well, check whether this this version of the Fibonacci problem
this version of the Fibonacci problem computing F of N
computing F of N is already in our dictionary.
is already in our dictionary. So if that key is already in the
So if that key is already in the dictionary, we return the corresponding
dictionary, we return the corresponding value in the dictionary.
value in the dictionary. So
So and then once we've computed the N
and then once we've computed the N Fibonacci number, if we bothered to do
Fibonacci number, if we bothered to do this, if this didn't apply, then we
this, if this didn't apply, then we store it in the memo table. So we store
store it in the memo table. So we store we say well, if you ever need to compute
we say well, if you ever need to compute F of N again, here it is.
F of N again, here it is. And then we return that value.
And then we return that value. Okay, so this is a general procedure.
Okay, so this is a general procedure. Apply to any recursive algorithm
Apply to any recursive algorithm with no side effects, I guess,
with no side effects, I guess, technically.
technically. And turns out this makes the algorithm
And turns out this makes the algorithm efficient.
efficient. Now there's a lot of ways to see why
Now there's a lot of ways to see why it's efficient.
it's efficient. Um
Um In general, maybe it's helpful to think
In general, maybe it's helpful to think about the recursion tree.
about the recursion tree. So if you want to compute FN, in the old
So if you want to compute FN, in the old algorithm, we compute FN minus one and
algorithm, we compute FN minus one and FN minus two completely separately. To
FN minus two completely separately. To compute FN minus one, we compute FN
compute FN minus one, we compute FN minus two and FN minus three.
minus two and FN minus three. To compute FN minus two, we compute FN
To compute FN minus two, we compute FN minus three and FN minus four.
minus three and FN minus four. And so on. And you can sort of see why
And so on. And you can sort of see why that's exponential
that's exponential in N because we're only decrementing N
in N because we're only decrementing N by one or two each time.
by one or two each time. But then you observe, hey, these FN
But then you observe, hey, these FN minus threes are the same. I should
minus threes are the same. I should really only have to compute them once.
really only have to compute them once. And that's what we're doing here. The
And that's what we're doing here. The first time you call FN minus three, you
first time you call FN minus three, you do work. But once it's done and you go
do work. But once it's done and you go over to this other recursive call, this
over to this other recursive call, this will just get cut off. There's no tree
will just get cut off. There's no tree here. Here we might have some recursive
here. Here we might have some recursive calling. Here we won't because it's
calling. Here we won't because it's already in the memo table.
already in the memo table. Okay, in fact this already happens FN
Okay, in fact this already happens FN minus two. This whole this whole tree
minus two. This whole this whole tree disappears
disappears because FN minus two has already been
because FN minus two has already been done.
done. Okay, so it's clear why it improves
Okay, so it's clear why it improves things.
things. So in fact you can you can argue that
So in fact you can you can argue that this call will be free because you
this call will be free because you already did the work in here.
already did the work in here. But I
But I want to give you a very particular way
want to give you a very particular way of thinking about why this is efficient.
Which is
is following.
So you could write down a recurrence for
you could write down a recurrence for the running time here, but in some sense
the running time here, but in some sense recurrences aren't quite the right way
recurrences aren't quite the right way of thinking about this because recursion
of thinking about this because recursion is kind of a rare thing. If you're
is kind of a rare thing. If you're calling Fibonacci of some value K,
calling Fibonacci of some value K, you're only going to make recursive
you're only going to make recursive calls the first time you call Fibonacci
calls the first time you call Fibonacci of K because henceforth it's been the
of K because henceforth it's been the you've put it in the memo table, you
you've put it in the memo table, you will not recurse.
will not recurse. So you can think of
So you can think of there being two versions of calling
there being two versions of calling Fibonacci of K. There's the first time
Fibonacci of K. There's the first time which is the non-memoized version. That
which is the non-memoized version. That does recursion, does some work. And then
does recursion, does some work. And then every time henceforth you're you're
every time henceforth you're you're doing memoized calls of Fibonacci of K
doing memoized calls of Fibonacci of K and those cost constant time.
and those cost constant time. So the memoized
cost constant time. So we can think of them as basically free.
them as basically free. That when you call Fibonacci of N minus
That when you call Fibonacci of N minus two because that's a memoized call, it's
two because that's a memoized call, it's you really doesn't pay anything for it.
you really doesn't pay anything for it. I mean you're already paying constant
I mean you're already paying constant time to do addition and whatever.
time to do addition and whatever. So you don't have to worry about the
So you don't have to worry about the time. There's no recursion here.
time. There's no recursion here. Okay, and then what we care about is
Okay, and then what we care about is that the number of non-memoized calls
which is the first time you call Fibonacci of K
is N. No theta is even necessary. We are going
No theta is even necessary. We are going to call Fibonacci of one
to call Fibonacci of one at some point. We're going to call
at some point. We're going to call Fibonacci of two at some point. And the
Fibonacci of two at some point. And the original call is Fibonacci of N.
original call is Fibonacci of N. All of those things will be called at
All of those things will be called at some point. It's pretty easy to see. But
some point. It's pretty easy to see. But in particular, certainly at most this.
in particular, certainly at most this. We never call Fibonacci of N plus one to
We never call Fibonacci of N plus one to compute Fibonacci of N.
compute Fibonacci of N. So it's at most N calls. Indeed it will
So it's at most N calls. Indeed it will be exactly N calls that are not
be exactly N calls that are not memoized. Those ones we have to pay for.
memoized. Those ones we have to pay for. How much do we have to pay? Well, if you
How much do we have to pay? Well, if you don't count the recursion,
don't count the recursion, which is what this recurrence does. If
which is what this recurrence does. If you ignore recursion,
you ignore recursion, then the total amount of work done here
then the total amount of work done here is constant.
Okay, so I will say the
I will say the non-recursive work
per call
call is constant.
is constant. And therefore I claim that the running
And therefore I claim that the running time is constant. Oh, sorry, is linear.
time is constant. Oh, sorry, is linear. Constant would be pretty amazing.
This is actually not the best algorithm this an aside. The best algorithm for
this an aside. The best algorithm for computing the N Fibonacci number uses
computing the N Fibonacci number uses log N
log N arithmetic operations. So you can do
arithmetic operations. So you can do better, but if you want to see that, you
better, but if you want to see that, you should take 6046.
should take 6046. Okay, we're just going to get to linear
Okay, we're just going to get to linear today which is a lot better than
today which is a lot better than exponential.
exponential. So
So why linear? Because there's N
why linear? Because there's N non-memoized calls and each of them
non-memoized calls and each of them costs constant. So it's the product of
costs constant. So it's the product of those two numbers.
those two numbers. Okay, this is an important
Okay, this is an important idea and so important I am going to
idea and so important I am going to write it down again.
In a slightly more general framework. In general,
general, in dynamic programming,
I didn't say why it's called memoization.
memoization. The idea is you have this memo pad where
The idea is you have this memo pad where you write down all your scratch work.
you write down all your scratch work. That's this memo dictionary. And to
That's this memo dictionary. And to memoize is to write down on your memo
memoize is to write down on your memo pad. I didn't make it up. Another crazy
pad. I didn't make it up. Another crazy term.
term. It means remember.
It means remember. And then you remember all the solutions
And then you remember all the solutions that you've done.
that you've done. And then you reuse those solutions.
And then you reuse those solutions. Now, these solutions are not really a
Now, these solutions are not really a solution to the problem that I care
solution to the problem that I care about. The problem I care about is
about. The problem I care about is computing the nth Fibonacci number.
computing the nth Fibonacci number. To get there, I had to compute other
To get there, I had to compute other Fibonacci numbers. Why?
Fibonacci numbers. Why? Uh you know, cuz I had a recursive
Uh you know, cuz I had a recursive formulation. This is not always the way
formulation. This is not always the way to solve a problem. But uh
to solve a problem. But uh usually when you're solving something,
usually when you're solving something, you can split it into
you can split it into parts, into subproblems, we call them.
parts, into subproblems, we call them. They're not always of the same flavor as
They're not always of the same flavor as your original goal problem, but they're
your original goal problem, but they're some kind of related parts.
some kind of related parts. And this is the the big challenge in
And this is the the big challenge in designing a dynamic program is to figure
designing a dynamic program is to figure out what are the subproblems.
out what are the subproblems. Let's say always the first thing I want
Let's say always the first thing I want to know about a dynamic program is what
to know about a dynamic program is what are the subproblems.
are the subproblems. Somehow they are designed to help solve
Somehow they are designed to help solve your actual problem.
And the idea of memoization is once you solve a subproblem, write down the
solve a subproblem, write down the answer. If you ever need to solve that
answer. If you ever need to solve that same subproblem again, you reuse the
same subproblem again, you reuse the answer.
answer. So, that is the core idea. And so, in
So, that is the core idea. And so, in this sense, dynamic programming is
this sense, dynamic programming is essentially
essentially recursion
recursion plus
plus memoization.
And so, in this case, these are the subproblems, Fibonacci of
these are the subproblems, Fibonacci of 1 through Fibonacci of n.
1 through Fibonacci of n. The one we care about is Fibonacci of n.
The one we care about is Fibonacci of n. But to get there, we solve these other
But to get there, we solve these other subproblems.
subproblems. Uh in all cases, if this is the
Uh in all cases, if this is the situation,
situation, so for any dynamic program, the running
so for any dynamic program, the running time is going to equal to the number of
time is going to equal to the number of different subproblems you might have to
different subproblems you might have to solve, or that you do solve,
solve, or that you do solve, times
times the amount of time you spend
the amount of time you spend per subproblem.
Okay, in this situation, we had n subproblems.
we had n subproblems. And for each of them, we spent constant
And for each of them, we spent constant time.
time. And when I measure the time per
And when I measure the time per subproblem, which in the Fibonacci case
subproblem, which in the Fibonacci case I claim is constant, I ignore recursive
I claim is constant, I ignore recursive calls.
calls. That's the key.
That's the key. We don't have to solve recurrences with
We don't have to solve recurrences with dynamic programming. Yay! No recurrences
dynamic programming. Yay! No recurrences necessary.
necessary. Okay? Don't
Okay? Don't count
count recursions.
Obviously, don't count memoized recursions. The reason is I only need to
recursions. The reason is I only need to count them once. After the first time I
count them once. After the first time I do it, it's free.
do it, it's free. So, I count how many different
So, I count how many different subproblems do I need to do? These are
subproblems do I need to do? These are the going to be the expensive recursions
the going to be the expensive recursions where I do work. I do some amount of
where I do work. I do some amount of work, but I don't count the recursions
work, but I don't count the recursions cuz otherwise I'd be double counting.
cuz otherwise I'd be double counting. I only want to cut count each subproblem
I only want to cut count each subproblem once.
once. And then this will solve it.
And then this will solve it. So, a simple idea.
So, a simple idea. In general, dynamic programming is super
In general, dynamic programming is super simple idea. It's nothing fancy. It's
simple idea. It's nothing fancy. It's basically just memoization.
basically just memoization. There is one extra trick we're going to
There is one extra trick we're going to pull out. Uh but
pull out. Uh but that's the idea. All right.
that's the idea. All right. Let me tell you
another perspective. This is the one maybe most commonly
This is the one maybe most commonly taught.
taught. Is to think of that I'm not a particular
Is to think of that I'm not a particular fan of it. I really like memoization. I
fan of it. I really like memoization. I think it's a simple idea.
think it's a simple idea. And as long as you remember this formula
And as long as you remember this formula here,
here, it's really easy to work with.
Okay, but some people like to think of it this way. And so, we can pick
it this way. And so, we can pick whichever way you find most intuitive.
whichever way you find most intuitive. Uh instead of thinking of a recursive
Uh instead of thinking of a recursive algorithm, which in some sense starts at
algorithm, which in some sense starts at the top
the top of the big of what you want to solve and
of the big of what you want to solve and works its way down,
works its way down, you can do the reverse. You can start at
you can do the reverse. You can start at the bottom and work your way up. And
the bottom and work your way up. And this is probably how you normally think
this is probably how you normally think about computing Fibonacci numbers, or
about computing Fibonacci numbers, or how you learned it before. I'm going to
how you learned it before. I'm going to write it in a slightly funny way.
The point I want to make is that the transformation I'm doing
transformation I'm doing from
from the naive recursive algorithm
the naive recursive algorithm to the memoized algorithm to the
to the memoized algorithm to the bottom-up algorithm is completely
bottom-up algorithm is completely automated. I'm not thinking, I'm just
automated. I'm not thinking, I'm just doing.
doing. Okay?
Okay? It's easy.
It's easy. This code is exactly the same as this
This code is exactly the same as this code and as that code, except I replaced
code and as that code, except I replaced n by k.
n by k. Just cuz I needed couple of different n
Just cuz I needed couple of different n values
values here, or I want to iterate over n
here, or I want to iterate over n values.
And then there's this stuff around that code, which is just formulaic.
A little bit of thought goes into this for loop, but that's it.
for loop, but that's it. Okay, this does exactly the same thing
Okay, this does exactly the same thing as the memoized algorithm.
as the memoized algorithm. Uh
Uh maybe it takes a little bit of thinking
maybe it takes a little bit of thinking to realize if you unroll all the
to realize if you unroll all the recursion that's happening here and just
recursion that's happening here and just write it out sequentially, this is
write it out sequentially, this is exactly what's happening.
exactly what's happening. Okay, this code does exactly the same
Okay, this code does exactly the same additions, exactly the same computations
additions, exactly the same computations as this. The only difference is
as this. The only difference is how you get there. Here we're using a
how you get there. Here we're using a loop, here we're using recursion.
loop, here we're using recursion. But the same things happen in the same
But the same things happen in the same order.
order. There's really no difference between the
There's really no difference between the code. This code's probably going to be
code. This code's probably going to be more efficient in practice because you
more efficient in practice because you don't make function calls so much. In
don't make function calls so much. In fact, I
fact, I mistake made a little mistake here. It's
mistake made a little mistake here. It's not a function call, it's just a look up
not a function call, it's just a look up into a table.
into a table. Here I'm using a hash table to be
Here I'm using a hash table to be simple, but of course you could use an
simple, but of course you could use an array.
array. Okay? Um
Okay? Um be it.
be it. But they're both constant time
But they're both constant time uh with good hashing.
uh with good hashing. All right. So, is it clear what this is
All right. So, is it clear what this is doing? I think so. Uh I think I made a
doing? I think so. Uh I think I made a little typo.
little typo. So, we have to compute
So, we have to compute another typo.
another typo. We have to compute F1 up to Fn, which in
We have to compute F1 up to Fn, which in Python is that.
Python is that. And
And yeah, we compute it exactly how we used
yeah, we compute it exactly how we used to.
to. Except now instead of recursing, I know
Except now instead of recursing, I know that when I'm computing the kth
that when I'm computing the kth Fibonacci number, man,
Fibonacci number, man, so many typos.
so many typos. Okay, so we're laughing.
Okay, so we're laughing. Uh
Uh when I compute the kth Fibonacci number,
when I compute the kth Fibonacci number, I know that I've already computed the
I know that I've already computed the previous two.
previous two. Why? Because I'm doing them in
Why? Because I'm doing them in increasing order. Nothing fancy.
increasing order. Nothing fancy. Then I can just do this, and the
Then I can just do this, and the solutions will just be waiting there. If
solutions will just be waiting there. If they weren't, I'd get a key error. So,
they weren't, I'd get a key error. So, I'd know that there's a bug. But in
I'd know that there's a bug. But in fact, I won't get a key error. I will
fact, I won't get a key error. I will have always computed these things
have always computed these things already.
already. Then I store it in my table, then I
Then I store it in my table, then I iterate. Eventually, I've solved all the
iterate. Eventually, I've solved all the subproblems F1 through Fn, and the one I
subproblems F1 through Fn, and the one I cared about was the nth one.
cared about was the nth one. Okay, so
Okay, so straightforward. I'm do this because I
straightforward. I'm do this because I don't really want to have to go through
don't really want to have to go through this transformation for every single
this transformation for every single problem we do. I'm doing it in Fibonacci
problem we do. I'm doing it in Fibonacci cuz it's super easy to write the code
cuz it's super easy to write the code out explicitly. But you can do it for
out explicitly. But you can do it for all of the dynamic programs that we
all of the dynamic programs that we cover
cover uh in the next four lectures.
uh in the next four lectures. Okay, I'm going to give you now the
Okay, I'm going to give you now the general case. This was the special
general case. This was the special Fibonacci version.
Fibonacci version. In general, the bottom-up does exactly
In general, the bottom-up does exactly the same computation
the same computation as the memoized version.
And what we're doing is actually a topological sort
of the subproblem
the subproblem dependency DAG.
So, uh in this case, the dependency DAG is very simple. In order to compute um
is very simple. In order to compute um do it backwards. In order to compute Fn,
do it backwards. In order to compute Fn, I need to know Fn - 1
I need to know Fn - 1 and Fn - 2.
and Fn - 2. If I can do If I know those, I can
If I can do If I know those, I can compute Fn. Then there's Fn - 3, which
compute Fn. Then there's Fn - 3, which is necessary to compute this one and
is necessary to compute this one and that one, and so on. So, you see what
that one, and so on. So, you see what this DAG looks like. Now, I've drawn it
this DAG looks like. Now, I've drawn it conveniently so all the edges go left to
conveniently so all the edges go left to right. So, this is a topological order
right. So, this is a topological order from left to right. And so, I just need
from left to right. And so, I just need to do F1, F2 up to Fn in order.
to do F1, F2 up to Fn in order. Okay, usually
Okay, usually it's totally obvious what order to solve
it's totally obvious what order to solve the subproblems in. But in general, what
the subproblems in. But in general, what we What you should have in mind is that
we What you should have in mind is that we are doing a topological sort. Here we
we are doing a topological sort. Here we just did it in our heads cuz it's so
just did it in our heads cuz it's so easy.
easy. And usually it's so easy. It's just a
And usually it's so easy. It's just a for loop. Nothing fancy.
Let's do something a little more interesting, shall we?
interesting, shall we? Uh
All right, one thing you can do from this bottom-up perspective is you can
this bottom-up perspective is you can save space.
Storage space in your We don't usually worry about space in
We don't usually worry about space in this class, but
this class, but it matters in in reality.
it matters in in reality. So, here we're building a table of size
So, here we're building a table of size n, but in fact, we really only need to
n, but in fact, we really only need to remember the last two values.
remember the last two values. So, you could just store the last two
So, you could just store the last two values and each time you make a new one,
values and each time you make a new one, delete the oldest.
delete the oldest. So,
So, by thinking a little bit here, you
by thinking a little bit here, you realize you only need constant space.
realize you only need constant space. Still linear time, but constant space.
Still linear time, but constant space. And that's a that's often the case. From
And that's a that's often the case. From the bottom-up perspective, you see what
the bottom-up perspective, you see what you really need to store,
you really need to store, what you need to keep track of.
All right. Uh, I guess another nice thing about this perspective is the
thing about this perspective is the running time is totally obvious. Right,
running time is totally obvious. Right, this is clearly constant time, so this
this is clearly constant time, so this is clearly linear time.
is clearly linear time. Whereas in this memoized algorithm, you
Whereas in this memoized algorithm, you have to think about
have to think about when's it going to be memoized, when's
when's it going to be memoized, when's it's not. I still like this perspective
it's not. I still like this perspective because with this rule, just multiply
because with this rule, just multiply number of subproblems by time per
number of subproblems by time per subproblem, you get the answer.
subproblem, you get the answer. But, it's a little less obvious than uh
But, it's a little less obvious than uh than code like this. So, you know,
than code like this. So, you know, choose however you like to think about
choose however you like to think about it.
So, I'm again, as usual, thinking about single source shortest paths.
single source shortest paths. So, we want to compute
So, we want to compute the shortest path weight from S to V for
the shortest path weight from S to V for all V.
Okay, I'd like to write this initially as a naive recursive
initially as a naive recursive algorithm, which I can then memoize,
algorithm, which I can then memoize, which I can then bottom-uppify.
which I can then bottom-uppify. I just made that up.
I just made that up. Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. So,
So, how could I write this as a naive
how could I write this as a naive recursive algorithm? This is not so
recursive algorithm? This is not so obvious.
obvious. Okay, but
Okay, but uh
uh first I'm going to tell you how,
first I'm going to tell you how, just as a, you know, an oracle tells
just as a, you know, an oracle tells you, "Here's what you should do."
you, "Here's what you should do." But then we're going to think about go
But then we're going to think about go back, step back. Well, actually, I mean,
back, step back. Well, actually, I mean, it's up to you. We could either I could
it's up to you. We could either I could tell you the answer and then we can
tell you the answer and then we can figure out how we got there, or we could
figure out how we got there, or we could just figure out the answer.
just figure out the answer. Uh
Uh preferences?
Figure it out. All right, good. No divine inspiration allowed.
divine inspiration allowed. So.
Let me give you a tool. The tool is guessing.
Okay, this may sound silly, but it's a very powerful tool.
very powerful tool. Okay?
Okay? The general idea is suppose you don't
The general idea is suppose you don't know something, but you'd like to know
know something, but you'd like to know it.
it. So, I like you know, what's the answer
So, I like you know, what's the answer to this question? I don't know.
to this question? I don't know. Man, I really want a cushion. How am I
Man, I really want a cushion. How am I going to answer the question? Guess.
going to answer the question? Guess. Okay?
Okay? It's a tried and tested method for
It's a tried and tested method for solving any problem.
solving any problem. Okay?
I'm belaboring the point here. The algorithmic concept is don't just
The algorithmic concept is don't just try any guess,
try any guess, try them all.
try them all. Okay?
Also pretty simple. I said dynamic programming was simple. Okay?
Try all guesses.
guesses. This is central to the dynamic
This is central to the dynamic programming. I know it sounds obvious,
programming. I know it sounds obvious, but if I want to fix my equation here,
dynamic programming is roughly recursion plus memoization.
recursion plus memoization. This should really be plus guessing.
This should really be plus guessing. Memoization, which is obvious, guessing,
Memoization, which is obvious, guessing, which is obvious, are the central
which is obvious, are the central concepts to dynamic programming. Trying
concepts to dynamic programming. Trying to make it sound easy because usually
to make it sound easy because usually people have trouble with dynamic
people have trouble with dynamic programming. It is easy.
Try all the guesses. That's something a computer can do
That's something a computer can do great. This is the brute force part.
great. This is the brute force part. Okay, but we're going to do it
Okay, but we're going to do it carefully.
carefully. Not not that carefully. I mean, we're
Not not that carefully. I mean, we're just trying all the guesses. Take the
just trying all the guesses. Take the best one.
That's kind of important that we can choose one to be called best. That's why
choose one to be called best. That's why dynamic programming is good for
dynamic programming is good for optimization problems. You want to
optimization problems. You want to maximize something, minimize something,
maximize something, minimize something, you try them all, and then you can
you try them all, and then you can forget about all of them and just reduce
forget about all of them and just reduce it down to one thing, which is the best
it down to one thing, which is the best one or a best one.
one or a best one. Okay, so now
Okay, so now I want you to try to apply this
I want you to try to apply this principle
principle to shortest paths. Now, I'm going to
to shortest paths. Now, I'm going to draw a picture which may help.
draw a picture which may help. Have the source
Have the source S.
We have some vertex V. We'd like to find the shortest a
We'd like to find the shortest a shortest path from S to V.
shortest path from S to V. And suppose I I want to know what this
And suppose I I want to know what this shortest path is. Suppose this was it.
shortest path is. Suppose this was it. You have an idea? Already? Yeah.
You have an idea? Already? Yeah. One thing you do is
One thing you do is you could
you could look at
look at everywhere you can go from from S.
everywhere you can go from from S. And say, "Okay, what's the shortest path
And say, "Okay, what's the shortest path to each of those nodes?"
to each of those nodes?" Good. So, I can look at
Good. So, I can look at all the places I can go from S,
all the places I can go from S, and then look at the shortest paths from
and then look at the shortest paths from there
there to V. So, we could call this, I don't
to V. So, we could call this, I don't know, S prime.
know, S prime. So, here's the idea. There's some
So, here's the idea. There's some hypothetical shortest path.
I don't know where it goes first. So, I will guess where it goes first.
So, I will guess where it goes first. Right, I know it it the first edge must
Right, I know it it the first edge must be one of the outgoing edges from S. I
be one of the outgoing edges from S. I don't know which one. Try them all.
don't know which one. Try them all. Very simple idea. Then from each of
Very simple idea. Then from each of those, if somehow I could compute the
those, if somehow I could compute the shortest path from there to V,
shortest path from there to V, just do that and take the best choice
just do that and take the best choice for what that first edge was.
for what that first edge was. So, this would be the guess
So, this would be the guess first edge approach.
It's a very good idea. Not quite the one I wanted, uh because
I wanted, uh because unfortunately, that changes S.
unfortunately, that changes S. And so, this would work, it would just
And so, this would work, it would just be slightly less efficient if I'm
be slightly less efficient if I'm solving single source shortest paths.
solving single source shortest paths. So, I'm going to tweak that idea
So, I'm going to tweak that idea slightly by guessing the last edge
slightly by guessing the last edge instead of the first edge. They're
instead of the first edge. They're really equivalent.
really equivalent. Okay, if I was doing this, I'd
Okay, if I was doing this, I'd essentially be solving uh single target
essentially be solving uh single target shortest paths, which we talked about
shortest paths, which we talked about before. So, I'm going to draw the same
before. So, I'm going to draw the same picture.
I want to get to V. I'm going to guess the last edge, call it UV.
the last edge, call it UV. I know it's one of the incoming edges to
I know it's one of the incoming edges to V,
V, unless S equals V, then there's a
unless S equals V, then there's a special case. As long as this path has
special case. As long as this path has length at least one, there's some last
length at least one, there's some last edge. What is it? I don't know. Guess.
edge. What is it? I don't know. Guess. Guess all the possible incoming edges to
Guess all the possible incoming edges to V.
V. And then recursively compute the
And then recursively compute the shortest path from S to U,
shortest path from S to U, and then add on the edge V.
and then add on the edge V. Okay, so what is the shortest path? It's
Okay, so what is the shortest path? It's delta of S  U,
delta of S  U, which is looks the same. It's another
which is looks the same. It's another subproblem that I want to solve.
subproblem that I want to solve. There's V subproblems here I care about.
There's V subproblems here I care about. So, that's good. I take that. I add on
So, that's good. I take that. I add on the weight of the edge UV.
And that should hopefully give me delta of S  V.
delta of S  V. Well, if I was lucky and I guessed the
Well, if I was lucky and I guessed the right choice of U. Now, in reality, I'm
right choice of U. Now, in reality, I'm not lucky. So, I have to minimize
not lucky. So, I have to minimize over all edges UV.
over all edges UV. So, this is the
So, this is the we're minimizing over the choice of U. V
we're minimizing over the choice of U. V was already given here.
was already given here. So, I take the minimum
So, I take the minimum over all edges of the shortest path from
over all edges of the shortest path from S to U plus the weight
S to U plus the weight of the edge UV.
of the edge UV. That should give me the shortest path
That should give me the shortest path cuz this gave me the shortest path from
cuz this gave me the shortest path from S to U.
S to U. Then I added on the edge I need to get
Then I added on the edge I need to get there. And wherever the shortest path
there. And wherever the shortest path is, it has some it uses some last edge
is, it has some it uses some last edge UV.
UV. There's got to be some choice of U
There's got to be some choice of U that's the right one. That's the that's
that's the right one. That's the that's the good guess that we're hoping for. We
the good guess that we're hoping for. We don't know what the good guess is, so we
don't know what the good guess is, so we just try them all.
just try them all. But whatever it is, this will be the
But whatever it is, this will be the weight of that path.
weight of that path. It's going to take the best path from S
It's going to take the best path from S to U because subpaths of shortest paths
to U because subpaths of shortest paths are shortest paths, optimal
are shortest paths, optimal substructure.
substructure. So, this part will be delta of SU. This
So, this part will be delta of SU. This part is obviously W of UV. So, this will
part is obviously W of UV. So, this will give the right answer.
Hopefully. Okay?
Okay? Uh it's certainly going to I mean, this
Uh it's certainly going to I mean, this is the analog of the naive recursive
is the analog of the naive recursive algorithm for Fibonacci. So, it's not
algorithm for Fibonacci. So, it's not going to be efficient. If I I mean, this
going to be efficient. If I I mean, this is an algorithm, right? You could say
is an algorithm, right? You could say you this is a recursive call.
you this is a recursive call. I'm going to treat this as recursive
I'm going to treat this as recursive call
call instead of just a definition.
instead of just a definition. Then this is a recursive algorithm.
Then this is a recursive algorithm. How good or bad is this recursive
How good or bad is this recursive algorithm?
algorithm? Terrible. Terrible. Very good.
Terrible. Terrible. Very good. Very bad, I should say.
Very bad, I should say. Uh
Uh it's definitely going to be exponential
without memoization. So, but we know we know how to make algorithms better, we
know how to make algorithms better, we memoize.
memoize. Okay, so you can I think you know how to
Okay, so you can I think you know how to write this as a memoized algorithm.
write this as a memoized algorithm. To define the function delta of SV,
To define the function delta of SV, you
you first check is S  V in the memo
first check is S  V in the memo table? If so, return that value.
table? If so, return that value. Otherwise, do this computation, where
Otherwise, do this computation, where this is a recursive call, and then store
this is a recursive call, and then store it in the memo table.
it in the memo table. Okay? I don't think I need to write that
Okay? I don't think I need to write that down. It's just like the memoized code
down. It's just like the memoized code over there.
over there. Just there's now two arguments instead
Just there's now two arguments instead of one.
of one. In fact, S isn't changing, so I only
In fact, S isn't changing, so I only need to store with V instead of S
need to store with V instead of S  V.
V. Uh is that a good algorithm? I claim
Uh is that a good algorithm? I claim memoization makes everything faster.
memoization makes everything faster. Is that
Is that a fast algorithm?
Yes? How many people think yes, it's a good
How many people think yes, it's a good algorithm?
algorithm? Better. Better. Definitely better. Can't
Better. Better. Definitely better. Can't be worse.
be worse. How many people think it's a bad
How many people think it's a bad algorithm?
algorithm? Still.
Still. Okay, so three for yes, zero for no.
Okay, so three for yes, zero for no. How many people aren't sure?
How many people aren't sure? Yeah.
Yeah. Including the yes votes.
Including the yes votes. Good. Uh
All right. It's not so tricky. Let me draw you a graph.
So if we wanted to compute delta of S  V,
V, I'm going to give these guys names A and
I'm going to give these guys names A and B. So we compute delta of S  V.
B. So we compute delta of S  V. To compute that, we need to know uh
To compute that, we need to know uh delta of S  A
delta of S  A and delta of S  B.
and delta of S  B. All right, those are the two ways or
All right, those are the two ways or sorry, actually we just need one.
sorry, actually we just need one. Only one incoming edge to V. So it's
Only one incoming edge to V. So it's delta of S
delta of S  A.
Uh sorry, I should I should have put a base case here, too. Uh delta of
base case here, too. Uh delta of S  S equals zero.
S  S equals zero. Let's say.
Okay, delta of S  A plus the edge. Okay, there is some shortest path
edge. Okay, there is some shortest path to A. To compute the shortest path to A,
to A. To compute the shortest path to A, we look at all the incoming edges to A.
we look at all the incoming edges to A. There's only one.
There's only one. So delta of S  B.
So delta of S  B. Now I want to compute the shortest path
Now I want to compute the shortest path from B.
from B. Uh well, there's two ways to get to B.
Uh well, there's two ways to get to B. One of them is delta of S  B.
One of them is delta of S  B. Sorry. Uh S  S
Sorry. Uh S  S came from S.
came from S. The other way is delta of S  V.
The other way is delta of S  V. Do you see a problem?
Do you see a problem? Yeah.
Yeah. Delta of S  V is what we're
Delta of S  V is what we're trying to figure out.
Now you might say, "Oh, it's okay because we're going to memoize our
because we're going to memoize our answer to delta S  V, and then we
answer to delta S  V, and then we can reuse it here." Except we haven't
can reuse it here." Except we haven't finished computing delta of S  V.
finished computing delta of S  V. We can only put it in the memo table
We can only put it in the memo table once we're done.
once we're done. So at this when this call happens,
So at this when this call happens, the memo table has not been set, and
the memo table has not been set, and we're going to do the same thing over
we're going to do the same thing over and over and over again. This is an
and over and over again. This is an infinite algorithm.
infinite algorithm. Oops.
Oops. Not so hot.
time on graphs
Okay, for DAGs, or acyclic graphs, it actually runs in V
or acyclic graphs, it actually runs in V plus E time.
plus E time. This is the good case. In this
This is the good case. In this situation, we can use this uh formula.
situation, we can use this uh formula. The time is equal to the number of
The time is equal to the number of subproblems times the time per
subproblems times the time per subproblem.
subproblem. Uh so I guess we have to think about
Uh so I guess we have to think about that a little bit.
that a little bit. Where's my code? Here's my code.
Where's my code? Here's my code. Uh number of subproblems is V. There's V
Uh number of subproblems is V. There's V different subproblems that I'm using
different subproblems that I'm using here. I'm always reusing subproblems of
here. I'm always reusing subproblems of the form delta S  something. The
the form delta S  something. The something could be any of the V
something could be any of the V vertices.
vertices. Uh how much time do I spend per
Uh how much time do I spend per subproblem?
subproblem? Mm. That's a little tricky. It's the
Mm. That's a little tricky. It's the number of incoming edges to V.
number of incoming edges to V. So
So uh
uh time
time for subproblem
of V, the number of incoming edges to V. So I This depends on V, so I can't just
So I This depends on V, so I can't just take a straightforward product here.
take a straightforward product here. What this is really saying is you should
What this is really saying is you should sum up over all subproblems of the time
sum up over all subproblems of the time per subproblem.
per subproblem. So total time
is the sum over all V in V of the in-degree
in-degree of V. And we know this is
of V. And we know this is number of edges.
number of edges. Okay, it's really sub in-degree plus
Okay, it's really sub in-degree plus one, in-degree plus one, so this is E
one, in-degree plus one, so this is E plus V.
Okay, handshaking lemma. Again.
Again. Okay. Uh now we already knew an
Okay. Uh now we already knew an algorithm for shortest paths in DAGs,
algorithm for shortest paths in DAGs, and it ran in V plus E time. So this is
and it ran in V plus E time. So this is another way to do the same thing. If you
another way to do the same thing. If you think about it long enough,
think about it long enough, this algorithm, memoized,
this algorithm, memoized, is essentially doing a depth-first
is essentially doing a depth-first search
search to do a topological sort to run one
to do a topological sort to run one round of Bellman-Ford. So we had
round of Bellman-Ford. So we had topological sort plus one round of
topological sort plus one round of Bellman-Ford. This is kind of it all
Bellman-Ford. This is kind of it all rolled into one. This should look kind
rolled into one. This should look kind of like the Bellman-Ford relaxation step
of like the Bellman-Ford relaxation step or shortest paths relaxation step. It
or shortest paths relaxation step. It is.
is. This min is really doing the same thing.
This min is really doing the same thing. So it's really the same algorithm, but
So it's really the same algorithm, but we come at it from a different
we come at it from a different perspective.
Okay. But I claim I can use this same approach
But I claim I can use this same approach to solve shortest paths in general
to solve shortest paths in general graphs, even when they have cycles.
graphs, even when they have cycles. Huh. How am I going to do that?
Huh. How am I going to do that? DAGs seem fine.
DAGs seem fine. Oh, what was the lesson learned here?
Oh, what was the lesson learned here? Lesson learned is that subproblem
dependencies should be acyclic. Otherwise, we get an
should be acyclic. Otherwise, we get an infinite algorithm.
infinite algorithm. For memoization to work, this is what
For memoization to work, this is what you need.
you need. It's all you need.
Okay, we've almost seen this already because I said that to do a bottom-up
because I said that to do a bottom-up algorithm, you do a topological sort of
algorithm, you do a topological sort of the subproblem dependency DAG. I already
the subproblem dependency DAG. I already said it should be acyclic. Okay? We just
said it should be acyclic. Okay? We just forgot. I didn't tell you yet. So for
forgot. I didn't tell you yet. So for that to work, it better be acyclic. For
that to work, it better be acyclic. For DP to work, for memoization to work, it
DP to work, for memoization to work, it better be acyclic. If you're acyclic,
better be acyclic. If you're acyclic, then
then uh this is the running time.
uh this is the running time. So that's all
So that's all general.
Okay, so somehow I need to take a cyclic graph and make it acyclic.
graph and make it acyclic. Mm.
We've actually done this already in recitation.
So if I have a graph, uh let's let's take a very simple cyclic
uh let's let's take a very simple cyclic graph.
graph. Okay, one thing I could do is explode it
Okay, one thing I could do is explode it into multiple layers. We did this on
into multiple layers. We did this on quiz two in various forms. Okay, it's
quiz two in various forms. Okay, it's like the only cool thing you can do is
like the only cool thing you can do is shortest paths, I feel like.
shortest paths, I feel like. Uh
Uh you want to make a shortest path problem
you want to make a shortest path problem where you or require that you reduce
where you or require that you reduce your graph to
your graph to K copies of the graph.
K copies of the graph. All right, I'm going to do it in a
All right, I'm going to do it in a particular way here, which I think
particular way here, which I think you've seen in recitation,
you've seen in recitation, which is to think of this axis as time,
which is to think of this axis as time, or however you want, and make all of the
or however you want, and make all of the edges go from each layer to the next
edges go from each layer to the next layer.
Okay, this should be a familiar technique.
technique. So the idea is every time I follow an
So the idea is every time I follow an edge, I go down to the next layer. This
edge, I go down to the next layer. This makes any graph acyclic.
makes any graph acyclic. Done.
Done. What in the world is does this mean?
What in the world is does this mean? What is it doing?
What does it mean? Double rainbow. All right, so
I don't know how I've gone so long in the semester without referring to double
the semester without referring to double rainbow. It used to be my favorite. Uh
rainbow. It used to be my favorite. Uh all right, so
all right, so um
um here's what it means. Delta sub K of SV.
here's what it means. Delta sub K of SV. I'm going to define this first. This is
I'm going to define this first. This is a new kind of subproblem,
a new kind of subproblem, which is what is the shortest
which is what is the shortest What's the weight of the shortest
So I want it to be shortest in terms of total weight, but I also want it to use
total weight, but I also want it to use few edges total. So this is going to be
few edges total. So this is going to be zero.
zero. Some sense, if you look at So here's
Some sense, if you look at So here's here's S and
here's S and uh I'm always going to make S this, and
uh I'm always going to make S this, and then this is going to be V in the zero
then this is going to be V in the zero situation. This is going to be V in the
situation. This is going to be V in the one situation, V. So if I look at this
one situation, V. So if I look at this V, I look at the shortest path from S to
V, I look at the shortest path from S to V. That is delta sub zero of SV.
V. That is delta sub zero of SV. So maybe I'll call this V sub zero, V
So maybe I'll call this V sub zero, V sub one, V sub two.
sub one, V sub two. Okay, shortest path from here to here is
Okay, shortest path from here to here is the there's no way to get there in zero
the there's no way to get there in zero edges. Shortest path from here to here,
edges. Shortest path from here to here, that's this the best way to get there
that's this the best way to get there with at most
with at most one edge.
one edge. Shortest path from here to here, well,
Shortest path from here to here, well, if I add some vertical edges, too, I
if I add some vertical edges, too, I guess. Cheating a little bit. Then this
guess. Cheating a little bit. Then this is the best way to get from S to V using
is the best way to get from S to V using at most two edges. And then you get a
at most two edges. And then you get a recurrence.
Which is the min over all last edges. So, I'm just
over all last edges. So, I'm just copying that recurrence, but realizing
copying that recurrence, but realizing that the
that the the S to U part uses one fewer edge.
the S to U part uses one fewer edge. And then I use the edge UV.
Okay? That's our new recurrence. By adding
That's our new recurrence. By adding this K parameter, I've made this
this K parameter, I've made this recurrence on subproblems acyclic.
recurrence on subproblems acyclic. Unfortunately, I've increased the number
Unfortunately, I've increased the number of subproblems. Number of subproblems
is uh V squared.
V squared. Mm, technically V * V - 1. Cuz I really
Mm, technically V * V - 1. Cuz I really Or I actually V squared, sorry.
Or I actually V squared, sorry. Get it right. I start at zero.
Get it right. I start at zero. And what I care about
And what I care about the my goal
is delta sub V minus one of SV. Because by Bellman-Ford analysis,
of SV. Because by Bellman-Ford analysis, I know that I only care about simple
I know that I only care about simple paths. Paths of length at most V minus
paths. Paths of length at most V minus one. I'm assuming here no negative
one. I'm assuming here no negative weight cycles. Should have said that
weight cycles. Should have said that earlier.
earlier. If you assume that, then this is what I
If you assume that, then this is what I care about.
care about. So, K ranges from zero to V minus one.
So, K ranges from zero to V minus one. So, there are V choices for K. There are
So, there are V choices for K. There are V choices for V.
V choices for V. So, the number of subproblems is V
So, the number of subproblems is V squared. How much time do I spend per
squared. How much time do I spend per subproblem? Well, same as before, the
subproblem? Well, same as before, the in-degree.
in-degree. Where did I write it? Up here.
Where did I write it? Up here. The in-degree of that problem. So, what
The in-degree of that problem. So, what I'm really doing is summing over all V
I'm really doing is summing over all V of the in-degree, and then I multiply it
of the in-degree, and then I multiply it by V. So, the running time, total
by V. So, the running time, total running time
running time is VE.
is VE. Sound familiar?
Sound familiar? This is Bellman-Ford's algorithm again.
This is Bellman-Ford's algorithm again. And this is actually where Bellman's
And this is actually where Bellman's Ford Bellman-Ford algorithm came from.
Ford Bellman-Ford algorithm came from. Is this view on dynamic programming. So,
Is this view on dynamic programming. So, we've seen yet another way to do
we've seen yet another way to do Bellman-Ford. It may seem familiar, but
Bellman-Ford. It may seem familiar, but in the next three lectures, we're going
in the next three lectures, we're going to see a whole bunch of problems that
to see a whole bunch of problems that can succumb to the same approach. And
can succumb to the same approach. And it's super cool.